The following content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
JOCELYN: Hi.
Jocelyn here and we're going
to go over fall 2009 exam
three problem number three.
As always, let's read the
question first. Calcium
ammonium phosphate dissolves
in water according to the
dissolution equation, for
which the value of the
solubility product, ksp, has
been determined to be 4.4
times 10 to the -14.
Calculate the solubility of
the compound in water.
Express your answers in units
of molartiy, ie moles of the
compound per liter
of solution.
So the first thing we want to
do is write down what the
question's asking.
Part A--
how much calcium ammonium
phosphate
can dissolve in water?
And we're going to
call this cs--
or the saturation
concentration.
Next we need to figure out how
to find this out, right?
So it gives us that the ksp--
4.4 times 10 to the -14.
So we need to know something
about the ksp and although
it's called the solubility
product, it's the same as
other equilibrium constants.
So equilibrium constants tells
us about the concentrations at
equilibrium and therefore
the maximum solubility.
Looking at the equation, we
have calcium ammonium
phosphate dissolving--
which is a solid--
dissolving into calcium
ions, ammonium ions
and phosphate ions.
As with every equilibrium
constant, we can write down an
equation relating to the
concentration of the species.
So our ksp is the product
of the concentration.
And a common mistake made
on this problem
was that people included--
students included the calcium
ammonium phosphate solid on
the bottom as you
normally would--
where you would normally
put the reactant.
However, remember that for
equilibrium constants, we
don't put solids in
there because the
activities don't change--
or the concentration
doesn't change.
It doesn't really make
sense to add it in.
So here we just look at the
solvated ions and we see that
we have a 1:1:1 molar
ratio here.
That's going to make our life
a little bit easier.
So now we need to figure out
what the solubility of the
compound is and to do that,
we want to look at
this chemical equation.
We see that for one mole--
so one mole of calcium ammonium
phosphate dissolved
gives you one mole of the
calcium ion, the sodium ion
and the phosphate ion.
Thus, we can say the amount of
calcium ammonium phosphate
dissolved, which we called Cs,
is going to be equivalent to
each of these concentrations.
Because we're asked for how
much of the compound is
dissolved, but we're given the
ksp, which is in terms of the
concentrations of these
solvated ions.
I'm sorry.
This doesn't equal
the product.
These are all equal.
Now we can plug the
Cs into our ksp
equation that we had before.
So instead of the
concentration of
calcium ions, we have--
it's equal to the
concentration of
the compound dissolved.
The same goes for the ammonium
and the phosphate, because
again, we have 1:1:1:1
stoichiometric coefficients.
And we can be a little
more concise.
Now it's just a matter of
solving for the saturated
concentration.
So doing some algebra here.
Then we plug in the numbers.
And we get that the solubility
of calcium ammonium phosphate
is 3.53 times 10 to
the -5 moles--
molar, sorry.
So that means 3.53 times -5
moles per liter of water.
That's not very much.
So we can say generally or
relatively this calcium
ammonium phosphate is not
that soluble in water.
So let's move on to part B.
Part B says, calculate the
solubility of calcium ammonium
phosphate in 2.2 molar
calcium bromide.
Express your answer
in units molarity.
Assume that in water, calcium
bromide completely
disassociates into
calcium 2 plus
cations and bromide anions.
This is basically asking
us for the same value.
It's asking us for the
solubility of calcium ammonium
phosphate, but under slightly
different conditions.
So we want to write those
conditions down.
Now we have to ask ourselves
why would the fact that we
have a concentration of calcium
bromide affect the
solubility of calcium
ammonium phosphate?
And the thing to remember
here is the
common ion effect, right?
2 molar calcium bromide will--
when dissolved in water, the
concentration of calcium from
just the calcium bromide will
be 2.2 molar, right?
Because we're told that it
completely disassociates.
So if we look at the
disassociation reaction, we
see that for every mole of
calcium bromide, we get one
mole of calcium and two
moles of bromide.
So having calcium bromide will
alter our answer from the
previous problem because the ksp
will always be the same.
It's an equilibrium
constant, right?
So even though it has to do
with calcium ammonium
phosphate, we have to take into
account that we already
have calcium in the system.
So before we start plugging in
any numbers, we should think
about this problem.
Do we think that already having
calcium in the system
will increase or decrease the
solubility of the calcium
ammonium phosphate?
Hopefully we can agree that it
would probably decrease the
solubility because you already
have those calcium ions.
So putting more calcium ions
into the water is going to be
harder and therefore less
calcium ammonium phosphate
will dissolve.
Now that we know what kind of
number we're looking for, we
can start doing the actual
calculation.
So again, we'll start with our
equation for the ksp, which
for calcium ammonium phosphate
has not changed.
I'm just going to rewrite
it on this board here.
But now instead of having
each of these be equal
concentrations, we
already have some
calcium in the system.
So we need to take that
into account.
And I'm going to call the
saturation concentration Cs
star because we're under
different conditions, right?
The calcium bromide does not
contribute any ammonium or
phosphate ions so those
concentrations will just be
determined by how much
of the calcium
ammonium phosphate dissolves.
From before, we can use what we
found in part A to simplify
this a little bit.
So in part A, we know that
without anything else, without
a common ion effect, that we
have decided will decrease the
solubility.
We have 3.35 times 10 to the
-5th molar solubility.
Therefore, we can say with
good certainty that our
saturation concentration with
the common ion effect will be
much, much less than 2.2 molar
because 2.2 molar is much
greater than our pure
solubility.
Going back to our equation
over here, that
means we can have--
and now we have a fairly simple
algebraic problem.
Dividing by 2.2 and then taking
the square root, we get
that the saturation
concentration under these
conditions--
2.2 molar calcium bromide--
will be 1.41 times 10
to the -7 molar.
And going back to our answer
from part A, we see that this
is indeed a lower solubility.
There's less calcium ammonium
phosphate that can be
dissolved and that makes sense
from our previous thought
about this problem.
And so now that you've
found the answer, box
it and we're done.